hey hallo okay mein name ist bill
schneider
aber ich bin in erster linie erden kind
hier mein text zum jahre 2016 schon 2014
stand ich auf dem schlauch hey 2015
fletschte mich auch aber für 2016 habe
ich echt voll kein gebrauch hey welt was
ist hier los
rassismus auf einmal ganz groß den hass
im netz den kannte ich schon du dummer
kleiner [ __ ] mit gez geldern rom
gehört heute show du arsch geburt ok
stopp kommt bitte runter sonst geht das
niveau echt untendrunter seehofers zäune
sind die mauern von trump hey sind diese
sparkurs eigentlich alle total darm habe
angst die welt wird untergehen mit
schrecken kann ich den atom knopf in
viel zu kleinen händen sehen
also das ist jetzt eine anspielung auf
charme weil über den mann gesagt wird
dass der halt zu kleine hände hat und
ich hab jetzt extra nicht gesagt dass
das trump ist damit es irgendwie offen
bleibt ob ich damit vielleicht auch
putin meine weil erstens kann sie auch
seines putin zu kleine hände hat und
zweitens habe ich gehört dass russland
mittlerweile echt krass gefährlich ist
jetzt bin ich im fahrstuhl stecken
geblieben und ich hatte machen
und an beiden waren russische hacker
schuld echt war
hey welt wird 2017 anders sein
ich leg mich hin und schlaf lange ein
bitte bitte habt ein nachsehen
und weckt mich erst 2018
dankeschön